you know it's an it's a unique time um
where there's so much uh information and
false information
and rumor and um biased
uh material going around about the u.s
border and um and i'm sure we've all
heard things and tried not to hear
things about it
um and so i wanted to get someone here
today who is
boots on the ground been there you know
that frontline bad boy
and i'm so happy uh today to
have fresh off of his 32 years of
service
working with the u.s border patrol where
he finished as the chief
border patrol agent of the tucson sector
we are happy to have him today mr roy
villarreal
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah burke chrysler oh man i love
that guy yeah he's so funny
dude he is an animal or the machine they
call him he's everything yeah
he's he he's like and he laughs all the
time
every time he's he's he reminds me of
like winnie the pooh like if winnie the
pooh went to college
and was like at a fraternity for a
really long time oh yeah you know
yeah like just like yeah
he's one of a kind man um so you live
over in tucson
yeah nice man i went to santa rita high
school for uh oh really
for a semester yeah my mom used to live
out on pantano
oh my gosh yeah so i used to be out
there and people would fight in the car
washes and stuff like that after school
so we didn't have any border control we
could use some border control right
yeah we could have used some border
control
out of santa rita high school man go
eagles um
so roy villarreal that's how you say
your last name nailed it yeah so your
position
with the border what was it exactly so i
recently retired from the border patrol
served for 32 years my position at the
time was the chief patrol agent of the
tucson sector
okay and that sector is about how big
uh 260 miles of border with uh arizona
border with mexico
okay and so when you're in charge of
that are you in charge of both sides of
it or
just one side just the one side so you
only have control over the u.s side
do they have do you know the person
who's in charge of the other side like
is there someone in charge of the other
side
well yes to a degree dealing with the
mexican government you're dealing with
different entities
uh their customs their immigration uh
federal police
local police there's a whole my rat of
entities you have to deal with in mexico
okay um so like on a day-to-day basis
kind of what were some of like your kind
of responsibilities like what are you
guys's responsibilities over there
so tucson sectors is the largest sector
in the border patrol and so i had about
4 000 employees under my purview
wow um and that was about 3400
sworn law enforcement officers and then
the rest were administrative folks
mechanics
technicians intel analysts radio
operators you name it there's a full
gambit behind it
the day-to-day operations in the height
of operations there in tucson we were
arresting about 500 to 1000 people a day
and that that includes um you know like
looking at the news right now you're
dealing with unaccompanied children
families and then that's about 30 maybe
of the work of the the workload right
now right and then the rest are all
single adults criminal aliens you've got
everything from
pedophiles rapists narcotic traffickers
heading in
coming in yeah wow so is it
and so man there's just so it's so much
it's like such a
um it's just a lot it seems it just
seems like a lot is it um
or so someone comes into the country
right someone's coming in illegally
um and i say that just because that's
the you know these are the
there's a lot where you have to have
some rules and and the rules are if
somebody's
in a place you're not supposed to be
then we're just going to use the term
illegally so
uh is that okay with you absolutely okay
that's i mean that's that's the
appropriate
legal definition you've entered the
country illegally right yeah like if i
went somewhere they would say that to me
if i went to a country where i wasn't or
i wasn't like didn't have the paperwork
done to be and then they would say
you're here illegally
um so if someone comes across and you
guys
apprehend them is it apprehend like what
do you guys do you guys take them in you
guys take them into a facility do you
immediately like
take them back across the border like
what kind of happens
so what's interesting about uh border
enforcement is is um
i think what happens with middle america
is there's there's a perception i don't
know if you've been down to the border
or what you take on the border is but i
think a lot of america looks at the
border um
through the eyes of what they've seen on
the news you know you look at san diego
you look at el paso
and they show an urbanized border you've
got cities on both side and fencing and
demarcation
a lot of what the border patrol deals
with is everything in between
out in the middle of nowhere rugged
mountains desert
it just there is i've worked in places
where there's next to
nothing out there in regards to
infrastructure it's just you and your
closest backup is 10 or 20 miles away
and you're in the middle of nowhere
wow and so we employ and i have to get
away from the wii because now i'm
retired but the border patrol employs
a whole buyer out of tools infrared
cameras
ground sensors we've got one of the
largest air
fleets in the us government in the law
enforcement realm
uh so you've got blackhawks uh
assortment of helicopters
unmanned aerial vehicles and so i mean
you're using all these different assets
to track so many hopefully to prevent
but to track them once they enter the
country
so if you see someone say say someone's
out on patrol right on an actual patrol
and then they see someone crossing into
the country
um do they like
tag them or like do they
what do you do like do you apprehend
them is it i mean
i would it almost has a like a freeze
tag type of vibe i feel like at a
certain point
it is it's almost like a game of cat
mouse you know um so i'll give you two
scenarios okay in an urbanized area
where we've got the you've got fencing
or
el paso you're saying like el paso um
even places like
douglas nogales arizona yeah um san
diego you've got
fencing or a wall you know under the
trump administration to change from
fencing to wall
right in those locations we've got a lot
of fixed cameras
these are cameras that are up on on
large poles and so you've got agents
that are monitoring and watching
and some of the technology that plays
into these cameras also detects
does change detection so if it's
watching the fence and all of a sudden
there's a change in that picture it'll
alert the operator
who then will call the agents out in the
field and then that agent he or she
will respond to the area or maybe
they're watching with binoculars and
they see them crossing over the fence
through a hole so they'll respond and
then they'll make the arrest
um it's apprehension a rest it's all the
same thing
okay um and then the second scenario is
as i described out the middle of nowhere
and that's more of the norm you're out
there and what happens is you may have a
ground sensor that goes off
somewhere near the border and you
learned
psychologically as human beings you're
looking for the easiest
path of resistance so you learn the
psychology of where people are going to
try to cross
okay and then you're also dealing with
uh one of the things that we can talk
about this shortly is
you're dealing with a criminal element
that's very effective
and i use the term they're professionals
at what they do smuggling people
okay and so they'll begin trekking north
into the u.s and what agents will do is
they'll find a spot where they can make
the arrest that's it's beneficial to
them
uh and they'll track them the sensors
are lined up in such a manner that you
can track the movement of a person
or a group of people you may use
infrared scopes you may
call on uh someone up in the air to
track the the group of people as they
move along
and then you'll roll and make that
arrest so if there's a so it sounds like
there's a lot of capabilities to know
when and where people are coming so it
sounds great right
it sounds like all these tools all these
assets um
but until you're out there and you get a
true idea of just how
it really is a needle in a haystack
because some of the areas that we work
in i'll speak to arizona
you have these arroyos and canyons and
brush and so you may have i may have a
camera an infrared camera
that's going to pan this way and if the
ground was flat and there was nothing
to obstruct the view easy right but
because someone can drop into a canyon
and these canyons can go for miles
or climb up onto a mountain and hide in
a cave your window of opportunity for a
rest
is very short so the agents when i say
they position themselves
they're finding an area where they have
great technology coverage and they know
the ins and out of that area so when
they
they go to arrest these people if they
scatter and run which happens quite
often
they know where to work towards to to
bring them into custody wow
yeah it's got to get you out there yeah
you would love it i've heard
yeah i've actually got offered we had
tommy larry came on as a guest one time
and she
is like you know she's like real um
she's big on the border on border
control you know she's a favorite of the
border patrol
is she she's one of the first that went
out to the border and invested herself
and
excuse me invested herself and got to
know the border of the border patrol
what's going on
right she's a strong advocate and a lot
of the agents really really
love her yeah yeah she's a strong yeah
she's definitely strong advocate but she
offered me to go sometime so
yeah i would love to go sometime so i
have an idea because i just see like
snippets here and there and it seems
like um you know a lot of the border
gets politicized a lot you know like you
see a lot of uh
like you you hear a lot of like oh
caravans are coming
or um children are being separated from
their
uh parents or their families like take
me into some of that scenario so like if
you apprehend a family then what happens
so everyone who's apprehended uh and
i'll walk you through from the point of
apprehension
to to getting into the station and in
some cases criminally prosecuted or
released or returned there's a couple
scenarios
as soon as that arrest is made the agent
um and what we have to recognize is that
we're still dealing with a criminal
element right so just like any law
enforcement officer
he or she goes through that whole
procedure of pat down checking bags and
whatever else
and you're dealing with people from not
only well
i think most people think about illegal
immigrants as being from mexico or
central america and that's that's the
focus right now
right but the reality is is we see
people from everywhere throughout the
world
really syria somalia egypt russia
you you excuse me ukraine you name it
people from those countries are coming
here um and
and they're coming through the boat
through the to the southern border yeah
wow the uh
and i often say this what gets lost on
the public is
border security is truly national
security right we're dealing with
cartels and this is a multi-billion
dollar industry
it's not a couple hundred dollars or a
few million it's billions of dollars
that are generated in trafficking and
smuggling of people and narcotics
wow the power and the leverage that
these these trafficking organizations
have is tremendous um you know and we
can talk about this in a little bit but
on the mexican side one of the things
that we have to contend with is
corruption
right uh and when you have an
organization a criminal organization
that's pulling in billions of dollars
you know dropping five thousand or ten
thousand dollars in the pockets of a
mexican official to look the other way
is nothing
yeah uh so this multi-billion dollar
industry
has a drive has a need to keep that that
uh
that money coming in yeah so the agents
are contending with
you've got unaccompanied children and
and when we say this i want to paint the
picture
a lot of these unaccompanied children
are young men between the ages of 15 and
17.
okay i'd say about probably half of them
and then the rest
are everything from a 12 year old
one of the things i see frequently is
you'll have a eight or nine year old
with a younger sibling who's about five
or six and sometimes a two or three year
old with them
and they're traveling thousands of miles
by themselves
to our border and then coming across and
it blows my mind i've i've got a
an eight-year-old i could imagine yeah
saying here here's here's the phone
number when you get to the u.s call this
number and somebody's gonna come and
find you i couldn't imagine sending my
child
out on this journey by himself oh we had
a four-year-old when i was growing up
that that wandered over to our house
like from the neighbors they used to do
a bunch of drugs next door
and um he knocked on the door he said he
was going to the dollar general he's
like four years old we're like
you're not going to the dollars like
just kids out of his mind it's like two
miles away right this guy's
you know so we sent him home man but so
but yeah i can't even imagine like a kid
going a really far
distance out of it and it's hot over
there i mean i lived in tucson for a
while dude it is
it's spicy oh yeah and take it back so
if you're leaving from guatemala el
salvador or honduras
you're traveling a couple thousand miles
two to four weeks
i think about a six-year-old or
eight-year-old doing this by himself or
maybe with a group of other kids
what happens between the moment they
leave their house until they get to the
border and when you get to the border
you're right there's the dangers of just
the environment by itself
the rio grande the desert the heat well
the heat and the cold
it'll kill you either or yeah it's a
good point then you have people that
will take advantage of these kids
yeah and one of the things that just
breaks my heart because i've seen this
countless times you get kids that are
rented
because one of the things that happens
uh is if you present as a family unit
here's roy mom a couple kids
i'm gonna get released and so what we
were seeing was kids being rented
you know and and so you've got a a
parent back in guatemala
who rents their child for fifteen
hundred dollars and that's a tremendous
amount of money in guatemala yeah
and so the kid is brought to the border
put in with
a pseudo family sits in detention and
then is released and then a handler a
smuggler
picks up this child flies them back to
guatemala
wow that's that's the best case scenario
right right what happens with kids that
just disappear
and we saw this happen as soon as you
identified that child because it would
take one or two sometimes three times
before the
the system would pick them up uh because
not all children are fingerprinted
and once you've identified them and you
you know you latch onto this group and
you expose it
if you can control and get that child
back into the hands of the parent
when if you can't if that child happens
to get released with that family and
then the smuggling organization realizes
that
the child is now blown right i don't
know what happens to them
yeah it's like is it worth them fly get
them up getting them a plane ticket or a
bus take it back to
guadalum guatemala is it worth or is it
just
cheaper for them especially after
they've already been doing a lot of
dirty business
you know uh to just not care or get them
into something else even worse
it's a business that doesn't care about
the person it's it's it's a business
that's driven by money so
whether it's trafficking whether it's
returning to the family best case
scenario and or
becoming an indentured servant you know
working in some sort of industry
being sexually trafficked all those are
realities of what we see at the border
yeah um yeah i've met i mean i've i
myself have
been involved with escorts and you know
that sort of thing we had a sex worker
on here one time
i've met girls before
um that have been presented as escorts
and you can
that i've just been like oh there's
something is not right with this
scenario you know this is not um
this is not somebody who's involved in
this because they want to be involved in
this you know that kind of stuff is kind
of sad to see yeah
and it's interesting because we'll have
such adamant like people
speaking so outspokenly about sex
trafficking in america
but the same people it seems we'll be
speaking about opening the borders up
but it's like
it just seems so uh i don't know it's
like hey how do you know that the people
coming across aren't
like yeah it could be pretending that
that's their daughter
you know or pretending that that's their
mom like you just don't really know the
scenario huh
no and the thing about it when i talk
about these criminal organizations
each uh trafficking organization
cartel owns a certain segment they've
got uh
cartel bosses that own plazas they're
plaza bosses
so you know it could be five miles or
ten miles of an area and so when you
come up to the border you're paying a
tax
in order to cross in that area on that
side on yeah from from the mexican side
of the u.s side so i mean
and when i talk about billion dollar
industry so a mexican national
he or she is going to pay between the
cheapest would be about 2500 all the way
up to about five grand
um central american five to ten grand
an indian national the tax they're
paying on the mexican side well
this is to get smuggled right oh that's
when you get muggled so you get to the
border this is part of your smuggling
fee you're paying a total fee of
let's say it's 10 10 grand right okay
but then when i show up at the border
this plaza boss says
feel i know you paid roy to come across
but you haven't paid my tax yet
so now you owe me 500 or 300 800
to cross here so you have to keep that
money on you on your person while you're
going that distance
it's a little bit of both you'll see
folks that travel with money in their in
their hands
and their pockets hidden away and then
there's a lot of money that gets wired
yeah you know it's it's a huge industry
uh
money being wired into mexico so like uh
i think it's
the number three or number five but part
of mexico's gdp their gross domestic
domestic product one of the the largest
uh
gdp earners is remittances from the u.s
and new mexico wow and it's the same
thing in central america where you've
got folks that are sending money back
so they'll wire a smuggler here you know
here's the 300 bucks that i can cross in
your plaza
wow it's it's just it's big bucks but
like an indian national
it's going to pay 20 to 40 thousand
dollars chinese
about 50 grand um someone who's uh from
a um
a uh a country that that may be on the
like
maybe perceived as being a terrorist
country not that they're terrorists but
could be received as such
easily 80 grand and that's what they're
going to chart that the
the smuggling organization or the coyote
is going to charge he's going to charge
and
and the the the organization in and of
itself is very disciplined in that
you've got folks that
they do the recruitment um they're all
over social media so you can go on to
facebook and
find sites that'll offer smuggling
and then so you've got the recruiters
you've got the handlers on the mexican
side that
that they house you and feed you until
you're being ready to be crossed
you've got the folks that will just get
you across the border and then you've
got those that'll cross you once across
the border
into the u.s and then you've got
logistics teams that do the transport
so there's all different so depending on
how much money you have
is the type of treatment you can get
along the way kind of kind of sort i
mean you're going to pay a lump sum but
each segment someone's getting paid
right um
the thing is with each segment as you're
getting paid along well you're not
in other words i'm paying you you're the
organizer right you're the responder
i give you my 40 grand and then that
smuggler as as the person's being moved
along
pays roy a portion okay i see somebody
else abortion
so he's breaking everybody off you kind
of have the guy that's the bank yeah
yeah exactly
um we had a question that came in from a
young lady right here let's uh pull that
question back up if you don't mind sean
and if you can hear birds this is our
new studio so this is our first attempt
in this new place here um
gorgeous thank you we got some there's
some robins nesting outside
hey theo hey roy i'm visiting the great
free state of texas
from michigan and my question is what is
one thing that you'd want people to know
about the border that the media won't
tell you
gang gang okay baby so that's a good
question yeah what do you what's
something that
that people don't know what's something
we don't know is like a regular citizen
unfortunately there's so many things but
i mean realistically the
the greatest thing that i think the
public needs to understand
is that it's not just about
illegal migration it's not just kids
or families it's the the greater threat
that's posed by these criminal
organizations i mean when you've got a
multi-billion dollar organization
that controls the border that can move
people
commodities freely that's problematic
yeah
it feels very problematic as like a
someone who's just in a place like
yeah it'd be scary if i left like a
window open at night and i knew that
people outside of the window had a very
strong business
and wanted things to come in my window
oh absolutely
and they're going to do whatever it
takes to get it done wow these aren't uh
they're not doing it for altruistic you
know good-natured purposes they're doing
it for the
mighty dollar do you have uh do you ever
have compromised
uh employees on your side yeah
unfortunately it happens
um the reality is again
get back i think it'd be hard to do so
i'll give you two scenarios the reality
is uh
the money is there um and so
people that are recruited in the border
patrol and we've got people from all
over the united states
um some some of which such as myself who
were born and raised near the border so
you
work in the border environment you've
got folks that come from back east
uh michigan places like that that have
never experienced the border and they
get down there and it's just this
culture shock
and uh we uh in in border patrol
parlance we used to call it a
a 10-4 scenario which is a police code
for everything's okay 10-4
but you call it a 10-4 because here i am
i'm a 4 walking into a bar and this 10
comes up and starts hitting on me
well what she's doing is she's working
you to corrupt you and so we've seen a
couple of
circumstances where that's happened so
the reality is is there corruption or
can corruption happen
yes right but the it's easier
in mexico than it is in the u.s uh
simply because of you know
the pay is different it's also
culturally accepted in mexico
um one of the sayings down there is
plumo plata um
give me uh give me the silver or give me
a bullet
silver being money right and so you know
mexico has been changing
working towards getting away from
corruption but it's still a reality of
of the environment down there
yeah um wow it's a real dark force over
there you're not really just
up against the people that are coming
across uh you're up against the
possibility of those people
um not just being like people fleeing
for a better life you're up against the
possibility of those people
being criminals um and then you're up
against
the the the both of those being
fortified and supported by by billions
of dollars
by by a really a strong running business
by dirty money but yes absolutely wow
yeah you know the other aspect too is
we've had uh cartels pay people
to join the board clean record get them
to join the border patrol and then
and then use them for information um
enforcement routes and stuff like that
to pass goods so
it's it's an everyday threat it really
is so
uh what about like so
trump had a plan to build the wall right
so that was like a thing
uh that was really big that he spoke a
lot about did they
start building the wall do you feel like
the wall was going to be effective
so uh looking at trump's wall
again 32 years of doing this when i
first came into the border patrol there
was very little infrastructure along the
border it was the
strands of bob wire if it was even up
right i remember uh being in a
high-speed pursuit
and i'm driving down off the freeway we
get into into the
the dirt and we're driving through these
ravines and stuff and had it not been
for another agent yelling out to me to
stop i would have driven right new
mexico oh really there was
nothing to demarcate the us and mexico
wow this is late 80s early 90s
so there's a different world then kind
of oh absolutely absolutely we were
arresting
anywhere from a million million half
people a year and every night it was
high-speed pursuits
foot chases we were catching a thousand
people a night and that's just in one
little station right
um i used to laugh because when i first
joined the border patrol i remember
walking into a station and there was a
somebody had a shirt up shirt for cell
on the back of it was an agent laying
face down with footprints on his back
you know what does that have to do and
he's like just get out in the field
you'll see and sure as heck you're just
getting overrun
every day really crazy absolutely crazy
so almost like playing red rover or
something and they're just coming
oh yeah yeah they would so uh if you
google it or look on youtube and you go
back to late 80s early 90s
in san diego that was the epicenter of
everything illegal migration
and what uh the migrants would do and
the smugglers would do is they'd line up
on the
tijuana side of the border and they
would watch the agents
and there weren't a lot when i came to
the border with about 2 500 of us
when i retired uh in december there were
about 20 000 of us so we've grown
tremendously but even that's
you know it's just it's not enough to
cover the border so it's increased bomb
was 10
by 10 fold and that's along the entire
border
yeah both the southern border and the
northern border so we've got about uh
16 000 agents on the southern border and
just under 2000 on the northern border
that gets forgotten too there's a threat
up there on the northern border wow it's
different but
there's still a threat up there right do
you um
when you have like a a family that comes
in oh wait
let me get back to that to just to the
trump wall so the wall was it being
built
it was right so one of the things and
this is often um
i think we talked about the media and
you know you get a certain sound bite
so the media doesn't give you the full
understanding or picture what we're
talking about
right when we were talking about the
border wall
what it is it's a border enforcement
system um it's the wall
but more importantly it's access to the
wall it's infrastructure it's a road
that leads to the wall it's a road that
parallels the wall so you can patrol
its power it's technology uh it's it's
this full package
right and so people often again they
think about the borders being
this urban area that you can just drive
right up to and and patrol very easily
when you go out in the mountains and the
deserts you need access and
what building the the wall did was it
gave us access to certain locations
so looking at uh trump's border wall um
there was some new wall that was built
and then more importantly there was
replacement wall
and i often laugh because people like
well it's not wall it's not new wall
well
when you get a new pair of shoes you
don't call it a replacement pair of
shoes it's right a new pair of shoes
right so we we have new wall built it
was about uh i think it was 450 miles of
wall that was built
wow yeah that's a decent amount it's a
decent amount and
the thing about this too is what the
wall does is and we looked at and we
analyzed
the border patrols where can we put wall
that effectively
shapes the environment for us so that we
can make a we deter people from coming
into the us
and then more importantly if they do
elect to come in the u.s where can we
shape it so that
it's advantageous to us to make an
arrest right
yeah because there's so much uh costs
too that go into like just getting
people out of like the middle of nowhere
and getting them back to a location
um and i just can't even imagine all the
costs that go into a lot of that
so the wall now are they finishing the
wall are they stopping the wall do they
know
no so so the uh when biden came into
into his presidency the new
administration put a stop to all wall
building
um which is very short-sighted uh and i
say it because of this
so in building the wall it's not like
they start at point a and then to b and
then the c what they did is it's
a and b here and eminent over there so
you have areas that are open
so you know they'll go in they'll clear
out existing fencing or they'll
grade for new wall and then they're
building in certain segments
and building to finish the wall so we've
got uh
in just in arizona itself probably about
300 gaps
some of which were are as small as
50 feet some as wide as a quarter mile
right in other areas where the wall was
built up to a point where you put a gate
in and you need gates
to go back and forth because you have to
do maintenance on the fencing and the
walls and
sometimes rescues and i'll talk to you
about that here shortly so they didn't
finish these gates
so now you've got 300 gaps in the wall
which means 300 vulnerabilities
wow 300 places that smugglers can push
people across and
one of the tools that smugglers use and
this
really upset me so we had families and
unaccompanied kids coming across what
these organizations would do is they
would charter
three to six buses they drive them out
to the desert because
on the mexican side their freeway
parallels the border
on the u.s side other than the cities
there's nothing on our side of the
border
nothing anywhere from geez i would say
30 to 80 miles before you hit any sort
of infrastructure from
the u.s mexico border so these smugglers
they'd hire charter these buses
they'd drive up 100 300 families and
kids
and they'd drop them off in the desert
and push them into the u.s
knowing that our technology was going to
pick up this this event
and then it would take us 24 to 40 hours
because it's again in places they were
dropping off in places where we had very
little access or infrastructure
so it would take us 24 to 40 hours to
get 4x4 vehicles into these areas
load up the kids load up the families
drive them to a place where we could
then get a van or a bus and then drive
into a station
and so when this happens and it's done
strategically again
this is about making money right right
it's done strategically so you drop this
group off here
and then i've got to close operations
for
in this particular location i shut down
a whole station which is about 450
agents
and i dedicated all of those agents to
getting these kids and these families
out of the desert because
what's going to happen the heat or the
cold is going to kill them and so when
your manpower is dedicated to this then
you get segments of the border that are
wide open
and what happens they run drugs through
there they run criminals through there
so it's all about making money it's it's
a cat and mouse game
you know a lot of people are selling
things online and vending things
and selling things and if you want those
things if you
if you uh if you're a seller you got to
get rid of the product
you got to push goods you know what i'm
saying fam
no one does that better than ship
station no matter how much you sell
shipstation makes it super easy to push
weight
to manage and ship all your orders from
all
your sales channels faster cheaper and
more efficiently
ship with any carrier import orders from
any
sales channel access discounted shipping
rates
do it all ship station
whether you're selling through amazon
etsy or your own website
whether you're using ups fedex or usps
you'll get access to amazing discounts
with ship stations small businesses
can now access the same rates usually
reserved
for those fortune 500 companies compete
with the big boys
shipstation has more five-star reviews
than any other shipping service
get our discount right now
use the offer code t-h-e-o to get a
60-day
free trial that's two months free
of no hassle stress free shipping
just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in t-h-e-o that
shipstation.com
enter offer code theo makeship happen
oh man cracking in a little bit of you
know
ah liquid death
are you paying uh off credit card debt a
lot
do you see that bill come in and your
day's been good but you get it from the
mailbox
and you can barely even hug your
children after that because your arms is
shaking
because you got so much damn debt
well when it comes to paying off debt
[Music]
upstart can help you get ahead
it's the fastest easiest way to pay off
your debt with a personal loan
all done online whether it's paying off
credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple
fixed monthly payment quit getting all
of those statements
get one with a five-minute online rate
check you can
see your rate up front for loans between
one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars you can receive funds
as fast as
one business day after accepting your
loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com slash
t-h-e-o that's up upstart u-p-s-t-a-r-t
dot com theo don't forget to use our url
let them know we sent you loan amounts
will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
theo so sometimes the the people humans
will even be used just as a ploy
to then run more expensive products over
oh absolutely
absolutely one of the things we were
witnessing too is uh i was in san diego
prior to going to tucson
and uh san diego at one point was
accounting for about 60
of all hard narcotics meth coke fentanyl
oh wow san diego yeah
crazy a lot of it come through the ports
and then some coming between the ports
but in arizona it started to pick up and
the difference in arizona was they were
making these little blue tablets
fentanyl tablets
which is much easier to smuggle and
transport than than you know bricks of
the stuff
so you would get and the way these guys
operate is it's just phenomenal
um so the scenario i described right
here's the diversion i send a group of
three guys
three to five all of them with a
backpack all of them carry well
the way they would work it is the first
guy would have 20 30 pounds of marijuana
right
next guy food and supplies the third guy
would have the fentanyl and he would be
carrying
probably 10 to the most 20 pounds of
fentanyl
and then the other two guys maybe meth
coke something else
and so this group of five would come
running across the border
we would hope that we would pick them up
you know if we're not what we try to do
is
not get so distracted that we completely
avoided everything because
again we had air assets technology and
so you'd see this group and then
the the the group had the five guys
the first guy his job was to get
arrested right so that
you have been dealing with him and the
and the guy with the fentanyl his job is
to get away and
the other four guys would do everything
in their power to make sure that he got
away
dang it just it's like crazy business
city chiefs almost kind of
you know it's almost like playing
against andy reid you know you know what
i'm saying like
they're coming with a plan oh yeah
absolutely absolutely
um man and you know what's crazy about
this too is uh
thank you again for the opportunity
there's i mean there's so much that goes
on at the border
and i'm trying to spit it out here and
my mind's racing because there's so much
i like to say but
you know i talked about the industry but
one of the things that that also happens
like these five guys that are coming
across
they're going to hike for 30 to 80 miles
through the desert
so these cartels have logistical
waypoints along there where they they
pay somebody to
haul in food and water fresh batteries
and so they're set up
in the desert and the mountains there so
as this group comes along they're
watching
so they got two jobs one is to resupply
and then the second job is to watch us
and it is it's it's a bear to catch them
i mean in order
to arrest these guys at one point we did
surveillance for probably
four to six months identifying all the
spots
right and then we brought in um
we brought in a whole slew of air assets
blackhawks and everything else and we
brought in our boar tack which is like
our swat team
yeah and uh bore star which our search
and rescue team all these guys are
badass yeah
and uh so we pinpointed all these
locations we coordinated with the
mexicans
and you know i mentioned corruption so
we had to coordinate with mexico city to
bring out a vetted unit
that we could trust ah and so that you
know they they did the blocking on
on the mexican side so these guys
couldn't run south and get away
and then we flew all these teams in at
each of these spots and they'd repel
down
and they run the mountains and make
these arrests but you know the amount of
money and effort that goes into it
it's tremendous but the unfortunate part
is you give it a week
maybe maybe a month and then they're
right back in business and so then you
have to replicate this you have to start
watching them and tracking them and
just crazy can you tag them or something
or shoot them with like a dart so you
know where they are they don't allow
that
no no see that's ridiculous to me a
little bit like it's almost like
especially for the guys who are doing
the smuggling
can you uh because we'll tag a goose you
know what i'm saying to find out where
he's having an
egg but you won't tag somebody who's
freaking just running
you know like anything across the border
um
do they have what about the smugglers if
you catch a smuggler can you prosecute
them is there prosecution against them
there is so one of the things that's
evolved over time is uh it used to be
the smuggler
or the guide would come across with that
group and you'd make the arrest then you
could work towards the prosecution
uh we also you have to recognize that
we're competing with all the other
federal agencies to get a prosecution so
you know probably one out of three cases
gets prosecuted why because some of them
and there's water right there too if you
need it right
um because so you're competing with them
to get a prosecution
yeah in other words so the u.s attorney
um his or her office can only they only
have so many attorneys so they can only
present so many cases
so they're looking for the best of the
best cases and you're dealing you're
competing with dea fbi
u.s marshals they all want the clout
from it you mean well
you want a winning record right if i'm a
u.s attorney
i want to have a record that's 100 no i
want to win every dog on case i present
right
and i also want to take the sexiest
cases you know right i don't want the
simple joe blow case
i want a case that gets headlines i want
a case that's going to make me look good
right so when you've got and every day
i mean you've got a tremendous amount of
cases you can come up with i'm gonna
hand pick i'm gonna cherry pick the best
case because
i want to win and i want to get a good a
good name behind myself oh the smugglers
so they'll
try and prosecute the best smugglers the
best smugglers or
a smuggler that's tied to a particular
organization um you know
so that again this was back in the day
when you get these guys in these
smugglers
now what's happened with technology
everybody has a cell phone
uh and some of the locations the cell
phone service has gotten to the point
that it
virtually touches every part of the
border now which means they can
communicate they can pull up
they can track as they're moving along
so smugglers will sit in mexico
and uh they'll text okay you're gonna
walk for a mile i'm watching you when
you get to this
point you're gonna turn left you're
gonna walk for three miles and then
gonna you'll get to this mountain you're
gonna get you're gonna get four dash
yeah like yeah it's just getting rid of
it it's crazy and you know we try to
employ technology and there's
um there's certain types of technology
some of which i can't talk about but
that we employ when we when we're and
stuff like that
stuff that can jam cell phones track
cell phones uh and more importantly um
one of the things that happened with the
trump administration is he
so the president gets to declare his uh
his top priorities
and for the longest time immigration and
border enforcement was it wasn't even on
the radar screen
with president trump it was in the top
five i think it was number three
and as a result of that we got access to
a bunch of agencies that have techniques
skills tools technology
that goes well beyond what we've ever
experienced and wow that really enabled
us to start painting a better picture
along the border
um you know everything from looking at
uh
it was kind of very frustrating because
you would look across the border because
a smuggler sits here
and he's watching you knowing that you
can't do anything to arrest him
unless i shouldn't say that
very far field between do you get to
arrest that guy because you have to work
the mexicans and like i said some of
these guys are paid off
and then you have to build up a case go
to mexico c and then sometimes you get
the rest
but um the the ability to do is just
i wish it was better um to be able to
actually process
guys yeah because really it's just a lot
of return so is it a lot of just
returning them
it is so so going back to the beginning
of our conversation
unaccompanied children there's a process
for them that you know we
take their information a lot of them
show up they have a phone number
written down some or a piece of paper
you'll contact that person and then you
start and you work at the consoles of
those countries whether it's mexico or
guatemala
and you start backtracking to identify
who the child is if they have family in
the u.s
and how you can connect them with that
family and they're they're
released from our custody into um
another organization that does the
housing and the feeding
until they can get them into a relative
or parents hands okay
and in some cases when it can't be done
then they work towards getting them back
to their
their uh family and in whatever country
they're coming from okay that's kids
family units are usually processed and
then they're released into the u.s
um so like if a mother and a couple of
two children come in
and a father then they're processed and
released
into the u.s yeah and
what do they have to go back to mexico
or they can just stay so
and this is what's uh looking at 2014 uh
look you think about the
the viewers question there one of the
things that's happening right now is
that
up until about 2010 2014 i think was
more realistic
most people coming across for single
adults right yeah so they were arrested
some were prosecuted some were just
simply returned back into mexico
in 2014 people began to realize that
they could exploit the asylum loophole
in other words i come here and i say
theo i want asylum right
and because of that i've got to process
you and then i've got to release you
and when i release you now you have
access to state aid
you get a work authorization and you may
not have a hearing for five years
and that's if you elect to show up and a
lot of people don't show up for their
hearings
so they don't necessarily qualify for
asylum um and i think that's
it's one of the shortfalls of this
because you've really
um you bastardized the definition of
asylum and for those that
truly need asylum now they've become one
of a million people asking for it and
you've
you've taken that away from them right
and at the same time now these folks are
using the system
against the system in order to benefit
from them
from it excuse me and so the family
units they come in they ask for asylum
uh they get into the u.s and they
disappear wow
you're criminal aliens they get
prosecuted and again we have folks that
um
robbers rapists narcotics traffickers
you name it
and you know they'll get prosecuted for
what's either illegal entry or re-entry
um or being an ag felon and they can get
anywhere from a year to some
upwards of ten years in uh in prison
yeah but then that's
a person that we have to take care it's
like it's still on the american tab
really yeah
um have you had a release people that
you know or cram it like release people
just
into the country and you're like this i
should not be releasing this person but
there's nothing i can do about it like
that's out of your yeah they're um
i've never had to release like a
hardcore criminal right you're gonna do
everything in your if you've got a
hardcore criminal and you know
that's a bad dude right you can do
everything in your power to make sure
that
he's either returned to mexico or
there's some
legal resource you can use maybe he's
got a warrant some sheriff's department
or something
so you can get them picked up and held
and then prosecuted right
you do everything in your power to do
that but i think what uh like looking at
today right now with the situation at
the border
um it's a crisis is it a crisis oh
absolutely
and i'll tell you why it's a crisis
there's a focus on kids there's a focus
on family units
um so in 2019 we had
we had a border crisis then and what
made it a crisis was these two
populations families and kids what they
do is they cause the system to
just to come to a complete grinding halt
right because there is no law
enforcement entity in the world that's
designed to house
or care feed children and families right
you know so we often heard um you know
negative backlash about oh
you know it's inhumane treatment and x y
and z but nobody's situated for that
but when you get i think it was 100
almost 200 000 family units and
something like 80 000 uncompany children
when you put that into the system that's
not designed for it
it just it stops it's gridlocked and
then everything else falls apart behind
it you can't prosecute
you can't house criminal aliens so the
system will collapse
it's a crisis on multiple fronts first
and foremost
because it's not being addressed the
flow is going to continue
right you know the unfortunate part and
for the border patrol
we're apolitical you know we're worked
for 32 years under different
administrations
every administration you know you you
give them the facts you tell them what
what's going to what you think is going
to work what's going to benefit
and then you step back and then you fall
on the line
this administration was briefed on if
you reverse
these programs if you take these steps
this is what's going to happen and
unfortunately sure that's what
happened so so we're in a space right
now where it's
uh do you feel like it's how bad is it
right now compared to what it's been
like during your tenure
so in 2019 um so like you mentioned the
caravan earlier
and that was the first of its kind we
had something like 10 20 000 people
this was a few years ago remember that
honduran caravan there was all of this
like
there was pictures and there was like
some of the pictures were even stolen
images from
um hotel rwanda i remember i remember
seeing one and it was like
a bunch of black guys with machetes and
i'm like i don't think this is the same
thing
but um that was a big thing how much of
that was just like a political football
kind of being kicked around and how much
of that was
like an actual group of people on the
way
oh it so it started out it was multiple
groups of a couple thousand and then the
biggest group was something like eight
thousand
and then they convened together first it
was honduras and then el salvador got
bored in guatemala
and so when these groups convened
together they they were close to twenty
thousand
uh when they hit the mexico border and
this is when uh the u.s put pressure on
mexico
mexico made an effort to stop them but
it wasn't a concerted effort it wasn't
like we're actually gonna do it
and then there was some writing at the
mexico guatemala border and then
eventually the crowd pushes through
and then what happened as they
progressed through mexico was
um cities decided that they didn't want
you know who wants 20 000 people camped
out in your city
so cities started chartering buses and
they would start moving these folks
along
and then when they got to mexico city
they housed them in a big stadium there
that
estadio and uh medical care food
everything else
and that and offering them jobs that was
one of the things that they that they
did is hey look if you're
looking for work we've got work we'll
give you a work permit we'll get you set
up
and everybody was pretty much intent on
getting to the us
so then they began and this was all
being organized and it was i mean
facebook and people were giving them
cell phones
so they got on the move again so wild
and
la bestia the train that goes comes up
from southern mexico
to the tip of south southern texas
mcallen rio grande in that area
that's what this group was planning on
taking free ride dangerous as hell
but free ride to the border so we got
the mexican government to stop the train
wow and then that caused this group to
to rethink what they were going to do
so they started moving towards uh
arizona and towards california
and so when they got to california i was
in san diego at the time they got to san
diego it was
uh along the way they had broken up some
went into south texas
some went into um arizona and then a
large group went all the way up to san
diego it was about 12 000 strong
and uh they were held up in tijuana a
lot of the mexican people didn't want
them there
wow um and again it's just it's this
large group of people that are showing
up on your border that you're having to
house and feed and care for yeah
and then what comes with it crime right
and some of it's directed at the
migrants i mean there
it's a population that can be easily
exploited so you know when we talk about
what are some of the things that happen
i certainly i worry about you know it's
a population that we're having to
contend with we're gonna have to arrest
but you also worry about these people
because
right because they're still huge every
human being yeah
and a lot of times what i saw and uh in
span of my career
when i first came on board at the border
patrol we were kind of vilified you know
there were corridors mexican songs
written about
these hard-ass border patrol agents and
in you know
fast forward to 30 years um before i
left i
i was at the border with some of my
agents and there was a group of uh
hondurans and this mom and her two
daughters came across
and brought him into custody and walked
up just to talk to him i want to get you
know right from the horse's mouth in
regards to what was it like
and i started talking to mom and she
starts crying and the little girls run
up and they grab my leg
and uh you know it chokes me up thinking
about it
it was after she calmed down i said why
are you crying and she goes
because i know i've made it and i know
that i'm safe because i'm in your arms
so the mentality of these folks is
they're doing this
dangerous trip from wherever they're
coming but they know that the minute
they get into our custody the minute
they see the border patrol
they've made it to the u.s and that
they're safe and gonna be cared for
and it was just it was the crazy
craziest experience for me because i
again when i first started it was like
whoa i don't want to be near the border
patrol
to i'm running for you and i i'm
embracing you and it's just crazy
man it's uh yeah it's so tough because
it's like
i have so much like human empathy you
know just like you know like um
sometimes almost too much i feel like
and then it's also tough like um
you know a business that doesn't because
america really is a business you know as
much as we like to think that it
it's also a group of people who are
trying to you know it's a society it's a
structure but it's definitely has its
ledgers for sure where
everything is uh you know accounted for
but then you get into this it's you know
this
it feels like just a lot of inventory
that nobody kind of really
is writing down you know um
are we getting a lot of people in that
we don't really know that you know we
don't have like paperwork on
um absolutely yeah absolutely so
uh one of the things that you have to
look at is you're talking about a an
unfettered flow of
of migration in the u.s us
prior to 2018 2019 uh annual
apprehensions were three to four hundred
thousand okay a year
a year across the whole border across
the whole border okay so again
looking back to 80s and 90s when it was
over a million million and a half
tremendous improvement right now we're
almost we're in that
700 to a million a year again so this is
this unchecked unfettered
population surge that's coming across
every year and that's what we encounter
and apprehend
right um you know it's it's hard to
guesstimate what's getting away from us
you know when you're distracted when you
have agents that are distracted
on families and kids that are giving up
and then caring for them
what's getting by us right so you know
every year there's probably
minimally 500 000 maybe upwards of 2
million people that are coming across
illegally
and coming into the u.s that we don't
know who they are um you know one of the
things with the current situation in
covid is
we also have to recognize that covet has
impacted these countries
probably much more severely than it has
us you know the medical capabilities
aren't
aren't uh the same as they are here in
the u.s right um
so you're getting a population of people
that are coming into the u.s
we're not doing coba testing on them so
you have the the
potential of another resurgence of covet
in the u.s
you know part of what happened um when
kovitz started back
you know last year is we implemented
what's known as title 42 which is the
ability to
when you come across i make the arrest
and i expel you immediately i don't
bring you into a station
my goal is to get you back across the
border and out of the us as quickly as
possible to minimize that exposure
um and they that was started during
covet yeah
okay so prior to that it was you were
arrested driven to a station processed
and with covid it was you don't even
come into the station and we get you out
of there
was that kind of nice that's great but
the only problem with it
is that so when i came to border patrol
in 88 we were just arresting people
you'd process them and you'd return them
right back to mexico and then you'd see
them again in the same shift or the next
day and so is this
a constant revolving door with title 42
we're kind of there again because all
the courts are shut down so there's no
prosecution there's no deterrent
you can't house them so you put them
back on the border and the smuggler says
hey
i'm taking you back across you know you
paid me i'm going to get you back across
and they just
keep on doing this so until we get the
the court system
turned back on um and then i think
unfortunately until the biden
administration recognizes that
but they are their actions and their
words
are having an impact they're driving
illegal migration until that changes
this is going to continue so when we
talk about crisis i mentioned the system
coming to a grinding hold
but the bigger issue is that there isn't
enough
from this administration saying you
can't come here
right you know you're going to be
prosecuted or the the reality behind
this whole thing
is and people may find this uh
quizzical thinking you know here's an
enforcement officer but our immigration
system has to be
revamped and you have to think about
this as it's it's a whole system the
enforcement part
and the legal part if you fix the legal
part then that enables the enforcement
part to focus on
the true criminals the really bad
elements when you have a
legal system that's messed up and is not
working well
that's when you get all these people
that take the illegal route and then it
just burdens border security
so you know i'm a strong advocate of
whether it's this administration or the
next one
somebody has to come in and fix our
immigration system as a whole
really but they can't do it half-assed
you can't focus on the legal part not
the enforcement part
or you can't take apart the enforcement
part and then bolster legal part you
need to do it simultaneously
so that you've got this immigration
system this umbrella
that works well so it's a really a
two-armed deal huh oh absolutely does it
feel
uh futile sometimes like the how do you
guys
maintain that morale if it seems yeah
what does it feel futile
it does you know one of the things i've
been talking to some of the agents that
are still out in the field and
it's uh you know it's the antithesis of
what you've been trained and what you've
been doing for your careers
arresting people and removing them from
the country or prosecuting them
and now you're arresting them and you're
releasing them into the country
the other thing too is when you release
them a lot of what's what's not being
reported is the impact on the border
communities
right oh i think about that a lot of
times like if you're a family that has a
house there
20 years ago or something and you you
know worked hard in a town and you
you know provided for your family and
you bought a home and then
what's that like for them yeah yeah so i
mean you have the potential of driving
the value of the home down
but the the the greater impact is
when we look at the the title 42 thing
it was also about preserving
our medical system in the u.s because we
wanted to make sure that we had ample
medical care for
u.s residents right right right if you
allow this population to come in it can
overwhelm the medical system
but when we have people being released
at the border so now you have to house
feed care for you have to provide
medical care for them
so some of these border communities
they're not equipped for that you know
not equipped for a surge of a thousand
or
twenty thousand people coming in on a
daily basis and so it overwhelms them
you know they don't have the deep
pockets to pay for this stuff and right
now the government's not
doing anything to help them out oh man
here's a question we have that came in
right here
uh from a fella right here theo
what's up bro this is a question from
roy
out here in johnson city tennessee just
wondering
what's the biggest uh
danger that you go through on a daily
basis out there
if it's uh certain wild animals or
uh cartel just curious gang gang brother
dang baby what's thank you for that
question man uh yeah bro what do you
think is like yeah what's kind of a
danger when you
when the guys leave on their details or
on their
what's some of the biggest dangers you
that you guys face and it could be
physical it could even be emotional
dangers that you feel
so there's a whole realm of dangers i
mean honestly so the cartels the
criminals that's one in and of itself
uh you're dealing with the environment
so if you're out there in the desert and
you're hiking around
dehydration hypothermia i've uh
tragically
i've had a number of agents that have
died from from uh dehydration
um at age hiking up patagonia mountain
had a heart attack and died really oh
yeah so
i mean the elements in of themselves are
danger and then you get
the criminal aspect um some of these
guys they carrying weapons some of them
oh yeah i don't want to be taken into
custody
you know um and at one point
particularly in arizona
we had ripoff crews these were gang
bangers coming from phoenix
down to the border laying in in the
mountains or the deserts out there
to rip off the the mules coming across
with the dope
and so we had an agent who got caught up
in the middle of a firefight and got
killed
and then know he mentioned wild animals
man we're dealing with uh rattlers out
there
um pumas there's some serious animals
yeah some buzzards oh yeah and then you
got the you know you go down to texas
you got the rio grande and some places
you walk right across it other places
you it's
dangerous as hell yeah so i mean there's
a whole bunch of things that can
unfortunately
law enforcement as a whole is a
dangerous job but there's a bunch of
things that can kill you out there
um what uh when you
is it hard for border patrol agents like
some of them whether
they're to set aside any political
beliefs they may have and just do their
job do you see any of that
or most of the guys like you said
administration just changes over time
and um and you guys just kind of stay on
the task at hand
it does bother you personally of course
you know you you want somebody that's
supporting your endeavors
um but you don't take it to work um
you know again because we're gonna every
four years you have the potential for
working for a new boss
right and the rules can change every
four years
what's uh i think what's what's
fortunate for the agent in the field is
that you know you're
you're tasked with enforcing the laws
that have been legislated by congress
right and so even though the president
may not like those laws
it's the law and it's hard for him to
change it or her to change it maybe
someday
um so you you try to stay apolitical but
it certainly bothers you when you're not
getting support
does it um does it
so yeah so obviously laws have to change
and it's it's a lot for things to
actually
change that would affect the way that
you guys operate but you're saying that
if it's not like
maybe more vocal support uh from the
media or from a president
or from an office then it
like like if if they see border say if
i'm a
coyote or a smuggler or someone who um
you know one of these plaza kingpins
who's helping run you know run guys
through my district or whatever to cross
the border to make more money
if i see this i know that the system's
taxed and i know to attack more
i know to ramp it up is that the kind of
thing that happens by
like when you see like that there's a
border crisis
oh absolutely take advantage of of
anything they'll exploit any opportunity
so the current situation absolutely
they're looking at if
i've got family units and kids over here
encumbering the agents and i can run
over here to the right of them um
it's such a it's interesting it's a
business it really is it is a business
and uh as a young man i started out in
um in
san diego i worked at a checkpoint and
we would see
these cycles that you're trying to get a
hold of what the next trend was
so when college you know college season
late august when kids are going back to
school
you'd see kids smuggling dope oh yeah we
used to smoke dude i remember one time
we took we went down to mexico
well we uh i remember one time we all
went down there and bought pills because
that was like something you could do in
mexico by pills
and we all took them then we all got so
we ended up stealing everybody's pills
from each other so now we're all
sitting around in a room we'd each
stolen each other's pills
and we're all lying everybody's looking
for their own pills and had stolen the
other person's pills and everybody's
just
lying that they had stolen and then one
time we got steroids
and we couldn't find a way to so we put
him in like a shampoo bottle
and i remember for a couple months back
in louisiana we literally would just
like
put like a syringe into a shampoo bottle
like i mean like we were horses drinking
out of like a
soapy trough you know oh my gosh i
remember the weights just kept slipping
out of my hands
for about three months um
so yeah i mean it's like i mean there's
definitely like uh
you know it's interesting because
there's like an allure for it when
you're an american kid growing up
there's an allure to go down
to mexico and it's almost like uh
there's just less laws less regulations
less infrastructure so
you you kind of have carte blanche to
kind of um
get into just more trouble is capable oh
absolutely
so you see it so so you're saying sorry
interrupted but you saw some people so
at certain seasons of the border
it's just spring breakers coming back
across you'll see college kids
uh smuggling because you know looking
for tuition books whatever money
oh yeah um and at one point you know as
soon as you catch on to that trend
then they shift to something else i've
seen senior citizens
um oh really oh yeah you know they're
supplementing their income
you know the uh the clint eastwood movie
the mule yeah
that's real i two years ago i was in
arizona
we caught a guy who's 68 68 or
68 16 i can't remember old guy
he was a mule smuggling dope and we were
talking
i've been doing this for years you guys
you look at an old man you don't think
of a of a
drug smuggler nah man that colon cane
baby are they putting cocaine
like are they doing the balloon still
what are people doing man i'd be worried
about uh
yeah that colon cane they used to be the
big thing people would like like swallow
cocaine balloons do people still do that
oh yeah
so uh every mechanism uh when i was
working in uh el centro this is uh
southern california
they were so every day across the border
and the borders it's such a dynamic
place if you haven't been there
you need to go down there experience it
and uh but
every day hundreds of kids cross the
border to go to school
and so what these organizations had done
is they took their school books
they hollowed it out just big enough to
put a key in there
and so here come these little kids every
day they'd walk across
they'd walk a block down and there was a
car they you know they tell the kids you
walk down there's gonna be a red mazda
the window's gonna be down shove your
book in there um on the way
home from school walk through here
there's gonna be a blue mazda
doors open grab your book and so you
would see this
you know until you catch on that trend
right here's these little kids dropping
off a book you know
it was an astute agent who's like what
the hell are they doing went over looked
in and they're you know a dozen books in
there
yeah so so so kids get used a lot
huh yeah because they're not gonna get
prosecuted uh
so they'll get used and uh to to bring
that stuff over
uh what's unfortunate in these kids that
you know they migrate to the next level
right because they're already caught in
the game yeah yeah and it's
it's not it's not a pleasant game it's
not type type of game where you can be
like
yeah i'm not going to do it today you
know there's consequences on this
other side and these aren't nice people
yeah
man it must be such a trying position
that you guys are in then
um because you're the human
element that's right there at the front
so you
it's like do i have to follow these laws
but sometimes you're going to have to
turn a kid over to an organization or to
a country to an environment to a
structure
that doesn't really care about it as
much
do is there enough like by allowing
like some of the leniencies that we have
here are we
making it harder do we make it easier on
these countries like
do we make it less responsibility on
these countries to police their own
you their own like um not really police
but to
to run their own societies well like are
we alleviating like pressures on them to
like if we stop things are they gonna
have to
deal with would that believe more on
their plate to deal with to actually get
their
get like a better act together yeah so
there's causing consequence um
sorry it took me so long to ask too i
just it's hard to be smart sometimes and
it's hard
another hurts my neck there's certainly
causing consequences and one of the
things you have to understand also is
there's a culture there you know you're
you're dealing with a culture
that doesn't necessarily match up lying
for lying with the us culture right you
know what's acceptable there may not be
acceptable here
um you know migrating here from from
mexico for the longest time it was just
part of growing up you hit 1516 you were
expected to migrate to the us
start working and send money back home
right um so there's a cultural thing
that we're dealing with and then
anything we do on the u.s side certainly
has a trickle-down effect it's going to
have some sort of reaction to mexico
i dealt a lot with again mexican
government from
their u.s attorney's office their
federal police mexican military has a
big part on border enforcement down
there
um you know one of their complaints was
when you know when you when you do
enforcement you know it's very one-sided
and it has been for years and i felt
guilty when i finally recognized it was
a mexican general where
we were in a meeting in tijuana and and
uh i got to tell you i
always loved meeting with the mexican
generals because it's it's just a
it's a different world the level of
treatment you get and we'll talk about
culture in a second on that but um
he says hey roy you know you always we
focus on what you want i need you to
focus on
what i want because all we do is look at
stuff going north
you don't take the time and look at
what's coming south in other words we're
going to send drugs north
and this money's coming south and these
weapons are coming south
and the combination of the weapons and
the money which buys the weapons
is messing up my society and and tijuana
was just it was a horrendous place for
border violence for cartel action
um there was just deaths every day and
so he's like
you need to help me do something to stop
some of this from coming
into my country and it wasn't until then
i kind of realized that
yeah it's just a god it's crazy i mean
it's just such a
do you feel like there's like a solution
do you feel like
what would help like what do you think
could help
oh man there are so many things that
could help okay you know it in
so the border crisis is a now thing okay
and we need the government
to step and i'm not not the government
we need congress
we need the white house but more i think
congress more anything kind of to
to get in the game right um you know if
i can be blunt it's congress needs to
get its head out of his ass
and start doing something right they
have the power of the purse and the
power to legislate
right um they need to apply the purse
towards addressing this
um helping with the kids the family
units they need to legislate
they need to revamp the entire
immigration system and uh
you know i i applaud the bite
administration for looking at you know
what do we do to invest
in the source you know where are these
people coming from right
that's great and we always try to do
economic redevelopment these countries
but they have to recognize that you
could you can't put a billion dollars
in el salvador today and expect it to
stop this flow
right you have to recognize that it's
going to take 10 or 20 years before
that plan comes to fruition so in order
to make things better it's
it's revamping the immigration system
it's helping some of these sending
countries
but it's also having a very strong
effective
immigration system that includes the
border enforcement right you just you
can't undermine it
and whether it's technology more agents
more infrastructure whatever it may be
you need to secure that border
man so so you have to have the border
you have to have the actual
boots on the ground they need help and
then the legislature you have to
have better ways to legislate and just
process things yeah
congress has to do its job i mean it
really hasn't done anything towards
um addressing the problem and a lot of
what's going on right now is
uh congress's fault from the last two or
three years because
a lot of the funding that was earmarked
for detention for remodeling detention
facilities
was removed from the budget because part
of the intent was to ensure that people
were being released
okay so now you fast forward two years
and what's happening we can't hold these
people so we have to release them
so it's it's a vicious cyclical game and
i i would just hope that uh our elected
officials just
focus on the problem it not only for the
humanity of these kids
and these families but also for the
bigger aspect of the border security the
one thing we didn't touch was terrorism
yeah i assure you and i can't speak to
specifics because there's
classifications behind it
but there are folks that have terrorist
ties terrorist training that are intent
on hurting us
that have come across our southern
border so you're seeing so you
definitely see people that you're like
oh this is not a
mexican person looking for asylum you
see
right yeah yeah and you know and i
mentioned the the amount of money that's
charged
these guys are paying big bucks um and
for like right after 9 11 a lot of the
smugglers
refused to have anything to do with
anybody that that came from the middle
eastern country
just because they kind of paint
everybody with a wide brush you're
probably a terrorist
right um so even the smugglers had like
a there's sort of a code of honor right
but you get away from 911 we kind of
forget about it like man if you smoke
that guy and he's gonna blow up the
country we'll have no place to smuggle
exactly but uh
but now it's just really open range huh
it is to a degree i mean there are
it's funny to think about this because
it it to a degree it's almost a
symbiotic relationship because you do
have some smugglers who
one thing that everybody despises is a
pedophile right and uh
if they know you're a pedophile or you
do something in their midst and they're
you know hurting a kid or something if
they don't
beat your ass or kill you they'll shove
you across the border with a little note
let you know
who he is you guys know yeah oh wow i've
seen i've
i've seen that on a couple occasions
where somebody's left on the other side
of the border tied to a tree or cuffed
up and with a little note hey this guy's
a
check your records wow so there i mean
there's a little bit of street justice a
little bit of ethics on there but
they're still driven by the almighty
dollar
um and i would hope that as if it
related to terrorist
stuff that they would still refrain from
it because it it harms both
yeah you know yeah knock knock who's
there
it's super special
okay okay boys especially
today's episode is brought to you by the
kratom experts
at super specio if you've never heard of
kratom it's
it's an herbal supplement kind of like a
cbd but instead of coming from
the cannabis plant it's from something
closer to a coffee
type of tree cafe de arbol
that's right it can provide relief from
occasional
pain it can provide energy support and
it can
manage stress i might need to do a few
lines of it
right now unlike other guys super
especially keeps their kratom
the way nature intended unadultered
and pure that's right unadultered
unadultered you want the good stuff you
want to clean
up huh you i want the stuff you find
floating off the coast of miami in a
bundle that's what i want
and that's what super special offers
so if you're going to try kratom
which you should heck you've tried
everything else man
you used to huff gas boy
go to superleaf.com theo you're going to
get 20
off go to get super leaf
dot com slash theo that's right g-e-t
s-u-p-e-r-l-e-a-f dot com slash
t-h-e-o enter promo code theo for 20
off that's getsuperleaf.com theo
promo code theo better help
h-e-l-p you get timely and thoughtful
responses
you get connected with a real therapist
not somebody not your mom's friend who's
chatty and hits on you
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches
maybe you don't want to drive over there
to the help center in your town or
village
or um experimental
area where you live maybe you
don't want to be seen walking in there
in the back of the nudie shop and
somebody's back there giving advice
better help set you up with licensed
professional therapists
you can do it on facetime you can do it
on the phone you can do it over text
better help want you to start living
a happier healthier life today visit
betterhelp.com theo
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
join the over million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional that's right and you will
get
10 percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o if you need help go get it
theo um here is a let's get the one that
came up a minute ago
by the military guy in the white shirt
theo van what's up man it's uh
patrick bryant i'm out of kentucky but
i'm over here at joint base lewis
mcchord right now
i got a question for your man roy uh
how did he feel about the military
joining up with the border patrol a few
years back i was down there
with him out of fort knox i just wanted
to know what his opinion on that was
oh gang brother thank you man um
do you uh yeah what was that like was it
is it nice when other organizations are
on board does it get a little sticky is
there like kind of like a lot of
posturing or is it pretty fun sometimes
yes yes yes yes so uh it's it's very
sticky so you know we've got plastic
comatadas which prevents the military
from
taking any sort of uh enforcement action
so anything that they do
for the border patrol is um support
okay so when i say support um they can
fix our vehicles
uh they can run our scopes like our
infrared cameras they can run
uh they can do uh lplp's listening posts
outposts where you'll put a a group of
it's a great training environment along
the southern border so sometimes they'd
send out
snipers and they'd put them up on a hill
and they would stay there for two weeks
at a time and they would just report
stuff to us
but everything they do is just about
support it's not actually
put hands on or anything so to answer
the question
absolutely loved having the military on
the border because it freed up
agents to go and actually do patrol work
right plus it was a great training
environment for our military so
you know that mission readiness for them
when they go across the pond and then
the bigger aspect is there was
there was always this exchange of of
information and um
and and and know-how because some of the
things we'd learned from them
right but the biggest part was uh the
building of infrastructure
i mean they come in and they fix our
roads or build roads for us and
again to be able to get to the border
helps win that battle
yeah it's just so interesting to hear
you say that about that wall about the
fact that it was going to also provide
um like that there was uh that there was
electricity with it that
there was like uh just a little bit of
infrastructure especially out there in
the middle of nowhere
um that probably just would have helped
so much
i i'm telling you i'm inviting you come
out to arizona i'll take you out
there yeah you'll be shocked we'll we'll
drive from an urban area and we'll drive
three maybe five miles out and then all
of a sudden you're in the middle of
nowhere yeah and there's no border
infrastructure there's no
power there's nothing and again i think
middle america just has no concept of
what the border really means i mean
you're
you're out in the middle of nowhere i
mean i've driven through west texas and
that even gets like
you know even on i-10 or whatever that
is yeah it's like that gets harrowing i
mean i i know there was like one point
about 45 miles but there's just no exit
you know there's no
if you need gas or something you already
should have got it so yeah i can't even
imagine what it's like when you
i mean that's a long and interstate yeah
so i can't even imagine what it's like
when you get kind of uh
in a in a you're out in the middle of
nowhere i mean it's you maybe you have a
partner sometimes you're partnered up
sometimes you're not
your partner could be 20 miles away and
it's pitch black you're relying on your
radio if you have radio reception
um you know and i've got agents that
they're using for four-wheel drive
vehicles atvs motorcycles
sometimes just hiking out in foot you
park your vehicle and then you just hike
um utvs you name it i mean they're out
there and they're doing the job
in texas they're on boats you know and
we still use horses
right people laugh like why would you
use horses but they get you in and out
of places that you can't do with the
vehicle
yeah great resource and the horses uh
i i laugh because uh to them it's almost
like a game
they get to the point where they're
smelling and they hear people and they
start getting giddy you can film tents
up
a good friend of mine was on the horse
patrol and uh
he wasn't paying attention he wasn't
paying attention to his horse and let go
of the rains he was sitting there
with another agent and his
horse heard
a group of people over the next little
hill took off he fell off broke his arm
by the time they got up to the horse the
horse had circled up and basically made
the arrest
yeah the horse is up there learning
spanish and he's he's fixing his arm
um what uh so yeah with the kids it's
just such a
god there's just such a there's so many
little elements going on there
it's like it must pull on your
heartstrings sometimes but
are there other times where you just
feel like the kids are being used and
it's not about
um an actual like getting a better life
for a child is there that that happens
also
yeah you know um
the everyday at the border there there's
there's so many different stories
i think for those in law enforcement you
go from being a social worker to a
caregiver to
to the cop right you run the full mind
of things you have to do every day
and uh with kids it's just it's
different because you're
when you walk up and there's three
little kids it's a 10 year old and a
six-year-old and their two-year-old
sibling it just blows my mind because
you're realizing that
this group of kids just traversed
thousands of miles by themselves walked
out in the middle of the dog on desert
or i shouldn't say walking i mean
somebody drove him up there and pushed
him across the border
and they're left out there exposed um
and sometimes they may have that phone
number in their pocket sometimes
and i've seen it when they they break it
out it's gotten washed away because they
you know they're dirty or soiled or went
through a river
and then how do you find the parents you
know we've had cases where
an infant's newborns just you go out
there and you find them that are there
and
what do you do you know how do you how
do you track back the parents of this
child
yeah we and we've also had some some
cool stories where
uh this was in san diego where i don't
know why mom did this but she handed her
baby off to another guy
and they're coming across the border and
the agents went to make the arrest and
she runs left and he runs right she
didn't know who he was right
uh we end up arresting him she ends up
running back into mexico
and uh you know start the processing
asking the questions and he says
this is my baby i don't want you know
here i don't want it
and all of a sudden here we are at this
newborn we're thinking how do you where
do you find mom
wow and this is when you work at the you
know in this case it was the the mexican
consul and
and uh shepherd from guatemala and the
guatemalan council and you get the word
out and you get the word out to
on the south side of mexico there are
organizations non-government
organizations that
help these people whether it's food
housing whatever it may be
and so you put the word out and you hope
that mom is there right
or that maybe if mom actually made it
into the u.s maybe she gets a hold of
the council and
hey we found found a baby in this
particular case it took two days
and mom finally came up and said hey
that's my child describe the child to a
tee what the baby was wearing
and we were able to reunite them but you
know that doesn't happen all the time
yeah you know and tragically uh every
year there's
two to 500 people that die along the
border really oh yeah
it's it's it's a lot of exposure
exposure uh the dehydration hypothermia
um you know when they get to the border
they're not fully equipped and a lot of
what they're told by the smugglers is
take a gallon of water you're going to
walk a few hours and you're going to be
fine
and you get to the border and it's like
okay you're walking 80 miles
be very cautious with your gallon of
water we're not prepared for it but some
people just chug it right in the
beginning oh yeah
i mean we've seen cases where aliens
have got to the point that they're
you know they're drinking their own
urine yeah you know and i mentioned the
agents are out there in the same
environment also i had an agent who uh
he'd hiked all night his he was tracking
down a group his radio went dead
beginning of summer he ran out of water
um he starts to get disoriented
and uh this is uh so this shift started
at four o'clock
at about ten in the morning he realizes
that he's just in dire straits damn
and his radio's dead and so he goes out
in the middle of the road
writes a letter to his wife takes off
his uniform folds it up sets it down in
the middle of the road
and he goes over and he gets under a
bush because he's just expecting to die
and he's looking for any shade and
he's hoping that you know the uniform is
going to be seen by somebody flying over
when you lose communication with an
agent after certain we we do call
welfare checks on our agents right
and uh we couldn't find them and so we
started this massive ground search and
air search and
thankfully uh so this is like 10 o'clock
it was about one in the afternoon we
found him and he was
he said i was ready to go to god damn
yeah so it's it's a dangerous place but
you know going back to the kids and the
the fact that there are 200 500 people
dying on the border
yeah that includes little kids trying to
swim across the river that includes
little kids walking through the desert
and it's just
it breaks my heart i i can't express to
you that
you get a little a little bit
desensitized to it because you get
experienced with so often
but uh there's just so many times when
whether it's out in the field or i'd
walk into a processing station and i'd
see these kids sitting there and
it would just break my heart because i
would envision my kids
right you know is it the desperation of
the families to for a better life in the
us and we gotta admit we have the best
country in the world
bar none right right but it's a
desperation such that you're going to
put your child through this and then
expose them to this and it just it
boggles my mind yeah that feels like
such an intense
move because i've been to some countries
where i mean i think i've been in most
of the countries where
there's a lot of poverty and there's a
lot of like not much structure in this
even somewhere there's a lot of danger
and fear um
but you still often see families
uh just moderate that the best to their
abilities
and also they don't know any better a
lot of times
and yeah i just couldn't imagine uh that
that
that that would be such a it would be
such a
desire you know especially if you had
children yeah
like i would almost be like let's just
manage what we can here and be together
then take this
or or come across together you know
that's
one of the things that i understand if
you're gonna send your kids go with your
kid particularly right now
not that i'm advocating this right to
anybody but if you know that family
families bring or lose
release once you come with your family
yeah right yeah how much of the
responsibility ever falls on the parents
too you know it's like
um i hate to say that but i don't really
it's like
i would be upset as a child i think if
my if there were not responsibility kind
of taken by my mom
you know um but i know every instance is
different
yeah look at the culture too you know
there's this expectation but
not for a two-year-old four or
six-year-old that yeah a four-year-old
can't even work at walmart or anything
no
yeah and you asked about the traffic
aspect um two years ago there was a case
that came out of um arizona where they
identified some like uh i think it was
just under a thousand kids that were
being trafficked or cycled through
and uh here's one of the things that i
think a big misconception is
what happens at the border does not stay
at the border right it's coming to
every part of the u.s it's here in
nashville it's in new york city it's in
florida
it's in kentucky you name it it's going
there whether it's narcotics or
illegal immigrants and in this
particular case these kids were being
trafficked
and then the family units were also part
of this trafficking and
uh so when they were getting released
the usually either the mom or the dad or
they can put a bracelet on them
and then what we were finding as soon as
they got to the greyhound station or the
airport they would cut it off
but we were tracking them and so we
tracked them to three different
locations
and in each location they would arrive
so if they didn't cut it off
at near the border they cut it off when
they got to to uh to the
state that they're in and uh they would
get there
and then the smuggler would bring them
in and okay now you're part of this
landscaping team you're part of this
construction team you're going to be a
maid
and you're going to work off this ten
thousand dollars wow so i mean
slavery modern-day slavery right right
in the midst of us
um and the kids are part of that and
again it gets back to some of the kids
being rented
some of those kids would get there and
then they'd be flown back right you know
and when we when we brought that
organization down there was a female
who's responsible for those kids and
it brought me so much joy to see her get
prosecuted
man oh it's a lot
it is it's you know again i appreciate
the opportunity there's just so much to
that goes on with the border patrol and
you know we haven't really talked about
what the men and women do the tools they
use uh
we've talked about a lot about the
criminal aspect what's driving it
uh there's so much that goes on there
and and again it
doesn't stay at the border it's just
yeah yeah no that's the part that really
definitely starts to scare me too it's
like you know um
it just seems futile like if we're gonna
spend money to
have this and you know like we have a
military that's
not sitting around a lot of times but on
a lot of bases there you know
there there's they could use probably
details and and things to do at times
i'm sure some of them would
love the opportunity to even just go see
the border and see what it's like and
um and if that would help relieve you
guys it's just like
yeah why don't we try and use our assets
better
um it used to feel like when i was
growing up that there was a pride in
like we're america and this is like
you know we stand for our borders and
that they mean something and then
it feels like that that's kind of gone
away or the media at least is also like
really pushed that
you know uh everyone has a right to be
in america this sort of thing which
which is hard to contest because it's
like how did i get into america you know
or how did you get how did any of us get
here
um but at the same time it's like if you
don't have
some system of checks and balances where
like some inventory um you know there
used to be a program i think where you
could sponsor a family like a family
that came in
another family would sponsor the family
and so then you had like a tour guide
into america kind of and there was like
i i feel like at least then there's some
like social accountability
within like a fabric work of the society
but
i don't know man i mean what do you feel
like is some type of a solution or
something moving forward
it's the legal aspect it really is it
needs to be revamped you know what you
described about programs
refugee programs are well established so
where you're sponsoring refugees as they
come in
in different category from an asylum
seeker right um but
there are programs for that where it's
whether it's a church group or a
particular individual that supports that
refugee and then helps them
assimilate and you know become part of
america
really we the key is legal migration but
it's got to be a system that's just much
more effective and efficient
the reason people start coming across
illegally is
you may apply legally but it's going to
take you three to five years right and
then the categories
again a lot of what we have are
unskilled labor right um
you know i agree one thing that
president trump did talk about was
if we're going to bring people in why
aren't we bringing in more skilled labor
you know we're not
we're not the country that we used to be
40 50 years ago we had a great demand
for unskilled labor right
we have a greater demand for skilled
labor your technology folks you know
stuff like that
so if we're going to do this it has to
be revamped so that it's addressing
the particular types of skills that we
need but it's also done in such a manner
that it's just it's effective it's
we live in a world where we want things
now right nobody wants to wait two or
three years and that's
part of what's driving this illegal
migration is if i apply legally
a i may not qualify b it's going to take
me forever and then
c right now if i come across illegally
i'm going to get released
at least that's the mindset that's what
we're seeing on social media and chatter
and
debriefs that we do with the folks we
encounter and that's some of the stuff
that's really the worst because that's
how people are
learning about it and getting inspired
really like now's the time you know oh
yeah yeah
i mean they're they're on social media
facebook instagram twitter it's out
there yeah
they they feed this and i mentioned
earlier thirsty
yeah smugglers use those avenues to
promote it too so
that's so crazy man so i worry like a
lot of times like
in my life or just i'll try to it's hard
to make things fair in the world you
know it's really tough
and i'm sure in your job you guys have
this real semblance of like what's fair
here you know
um but then also it's like you have the
laws you have to uphold
um but i start to worry like
like if a lot of people come into the
country
and they are allowed to be here and then
eventually become citizens
then it really just kind of favors the
democratic party to let them
in because then eventually they'll
probably be democratic voters it feels
like
which i'm not saying that like no shade
against either a democrat or a
republican or
libertarian or paul revere anybody you
know but
um or pancho via anyone you know but
it doesn't seem fair kind of like it
almost seems like it would behoove
like a like a more like
leniency by the democratic party to have
the border be
more fluid because then eventually those
um statistically the people coming over
are going to vote
in their party and in their camp does
that is that like a realistic
possibility or no you know yes or no it
so i think back uh
it was 1994 bill clinton and that was
the first time that there was a true
focus on border security
when we started to build fences uh
started increased manpower and invest in
technology and he was democrat he was a
democrat yeah
so anybody can do it anybody can do it
absolutely you know you mentioned
the the potential for a a support base
i.e will these
folks eventually vote democrat it's
possible a lot of them getting into uh
unionized jobs that are
tend to lean towards the democratic
party so absolutely but uh
maybe that's too big of a jump it well i
mean they can go either way but
what i've seen a great example um my
mother immigrated here illegally
decades ago in which she first came
across uh and then legalized she's a u.s
naturalized u.s citizen
you know her viewpoint on illegal
migration is she's absolutely wrong this
is not the way to do it do it legally
but her her political viewpoint went
from
probably more liberal towards
conservative you know
and and over the span of time living
here and i talked to a lot of the folks
that have immigrated here
legally and they have the same mindset
it's
i think it depends upon your experiences
your education um
and and truly it's that sense of if
there's a legal process
why not why is it not being realized and
i don't know what's driving
the democrats but they certainly don't
want to recognize that there's a crisis
at the border
they don't want to recognize that their
actions are are actually impacting this
and driving it
yeah it seems like well i mean it's nice
to know that anybody so any party can
help
um no matter who's in leadership but
that yeah but that we do have a real
these are real issues oh absolutely you
know but it gets back to
they've got there are elected officials
they have a job yeah they need to fix
this
and get away from right left right
doesn't matter
this is real these are real people
yes these are real uh
service men and women that are going to
work and do trying to do their jobs
like let's at least if we can afford to
have the support for them and afford to
have systems that work a little bit
better we have these systems
yes it's like let's get them functioning
back in the 60s
it was the bracero program you mentioned
about a program so i was just thinking
about this
it was uh you applied for the program
and you came across and you worked in
the u.s for six months or a year
and then you went back to mexico a lot
of these folks
you know they're proud to be mexican
they're proud to be hundred where
they're coming from
but the economic opportunities aren't as
great uh in their home countries right
they'd prefer to come here work for a
short period of time and go back
right i mean we deal with uh even in the
us we deal with the transitory workforce
you bring that program back you could
you may have some tremendous success in
that now you've got a legal mechanism
which allows these people to come and
work here for short durations contract
work basically
alleviates the flow at the border of
illegal migration which then enables the
agents to focus on all the bad people
that are trying to come across and the
bad crap that's coming over here because
they're there
yeah yeah you know i think that's my
biggest thing is i like there just has
to you have to have a system of
inventory you have to like when a
teacher calls roll call they're gonna
have a class or
it's like you have to know who is here
you know you just have to
and you have to know why and um
especially in a day of age when we have
so much ability
to keep tabs on everyone yeah you know
um
you know the one thing too is you talked
about accountability and knowing who's
coming here one of the things
and i'd mentioned earlier they're
it's not a huge flow thankfully but
there's certainly a terrorist threat
there
yeah uh and some of the folks that come
across you know they they uh
there's an initial scrubbing and there
may be more deeper scrubbing down the
road
some of these are bad folks that we have
to keep tabs on and or
get out of our country as quickly as
possible yeah yeah i
look i i totally agree man and it's nice
to just hear like a lot of what's going
on and i think you did a really good job
roy just like sharing a lot of
information
and um and just sharing like in a
comfortable way uh
where people can really just kind of
hear that it's a severe thing
it is you know it is and it's it's man
you guys go through a lot
i commend you guys man i commend all
these guys and ladies out there
men and women some of the best uh women
in law enforcement are us border patrol
there's some
as a my wife's also in law enforcement
and i i applaud them there
i got to go man you promise you'll take
me out there absolutely you come on down
i'll take you out there yeah my mom's
moving back to tucson man sought to come
on down there oh yeah yeah i'll go get a
fist fight at this car wash by santa
rita
and then you go out there uh
roy villarreal thank you so much for
your service and uh
and for being here today just to kind of
um just to open some of our eyes and get
some rio
direct from uh the front lines
information man it's really helpful hey
another resource too
and and i say this uh the border patrol
finally got into the social media realm
look them up on instagram twitter
because they'll send stuff out on a
regular basis
in regards to what's happening at the
border whether it's narcotics terrorist
ties kids whatever it is
because you're not always getting the
full story for the media right you know
you're getting little snippets at least
this way you can get a broader picture
um go to the source yeah we'll share
that and we'll share that whenever we
post about uh about the show
um it's fascinating man thank you so
much for being here thank you really
appreciate your time appreciate it
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
but when i reach that ground i'll share
this piece of mind i found i can
feel it in my bones
but it's gonna take a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
on my heart shine
that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my hands
and these rails that i've been riding on
they want something